-I'm at a really nice time
in my life right now.
-Oh, that's wonderful.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Why does that get a laugh?
If I say things
are going well --
I just had my second grandchild.
-Congratulations!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-No, don't -- Wait.
Don't applaud.
My daughter's 13,
so we're a little upset.
But she's very friendly,
and we got to teach her,
you know, just wave.
-And it's the second one.
It's the second one.
-Well, she's 13, so, you know...
-Do you --
I want to ask this question
'cause I have a 16-month-old.
-Okay.
-And I'm now at the age
where he can be entertained,
so you try to entertain him.
Do you try to entertain
your grandkids?
Do you try to make them laugh?
-Yeah, I do.
And you know what happens?
That's how I spend my days now.
And that's why I feel good.
And you find --
You know, I spent so many years
writing material,
and I still tour as a comic.
But most of my time entertaining
is to entertain
a 1-year-old
or, you know, a 2-year-old,
and your sense of humor changes.
And you find that, like, even --
I got here yesterday,
and I went to a restaurant,
and the whole
"got your nose" routine
doesn't work on the maîître d'
as well as it does...
You know, I thought maybe
I'd get a better table.
You know what I did? In the
street -- You got to try this.
Go up to a stranger from behind
and cover their eyes
and go, "Guess who!"
And they'll keep guessing.
My record now is 35 minutes.
"No."
"Is it Paul?" "No."
"David?" "No."
New York is real weird
for me in the street.
My daughter before --
She's not 13.
That was a --
She's watching, so she --
You got to know that I joke,
and that's how you were able
to grow up in the house
you grew up in.
But I --
No, I'm just explaining to her.
She'll go,
"Why did you say I was 13?"
But when she was here,
she was pregnant,
and I don't know
if your wife experienced this.
Do you live right in the city?
-Yes, we do.
-Did you find that strangers
would touch her stomach?
-Yes.
-Would actually touch --
They go up to a pregnant woman,
and they would go, "Oh, when?"
Like, I would never
put my hand on a woman --
First of all,
what if she's not pregnant?
Like, when --
It's like,
"When...did you have lunch?
Because it looks like
you really enjoyed it."
-So helpful.
-It is.
-I feel like nobody ever tells
you these helpful tips.
-That's why I'm here.
I'm here to tell you.
You know what's funny?
I'm looking at --
What's your name?
You're a beautiful young lady.
Beyoncé's drummer.
-Joy.
-Venzella over there.
-Yeah. You were looking at me
like you were disgusted
when I said --
Did I disgust you?
-I'm just --
-A little bit.
-Just a little bit?
-Just a little bit.
-Sorry.
-I'm sorry.
-We try to not have
disgusted drummers
in the eye line of the guests.